[Music]
a trend has developed in recent years
for nfl teams when a player is fired
they get this great graphic thank you
morgan moses now get the hell out of
here i
i just i
why are you so mean about look they're
they're telling the guy to leave they're
telling him hey you know you're due to
make seven and a half million dollars
this year and we have the right to rip
up your contract whenever you want and
today's the day that we're gonna do it
bye bye
um
it's a cold hard business and i
understand
that they don't want us to realize it's
a cold hard business that football is
family that sells a lot better than
football is a cold hard business in
which we save football as family so you
don't realize it's a cold hard business
shireen
it's still a cold hard business
well yeah and you know we've talked
about fans
siding with the billionaires rather than
the millionaire players and that just
always befuddles me because i'm always
on the side of the players over the
billionaire owners and they can tear up
the contracts and i get why players do
what they do when they hold out and they
seek more money and fans get mad but
this is why because a team can just move
on from you and say bye bye as you said
and that's what washington did with
morgan moses yesterday bye bye you
couldn't find a trade partner so we're
moving on go find your own team and good
luck by the way finding a seven million
dollar offer from anybody
now that stan kroenke is angrily shaking
his fist at shireen while he eats his
post toasties morgan moses a free agent
after being released yesterday it does
create cap space nearly 8 million
dollars and this move was set up by the
acquisition of charles leno the former
bears tackle leno plays left tackle now
for washington cornelius lucas who
played left tackle right season moves to
the right side and see you later morgan
moses we create cap savings we create
cash we move on they tried to trade him
like we
that's just it's so obvious now hey so
and so is gonna get released
and
and
then a day later he does if they don't
find a trade partner it's all about
trying to get someone to say oh before
you cut him we'll we'll give you
something for him so we don't have to go
out and try to sign him on the open
market that's why a team would do it you
want to get the contract you're not
uncomfortable with the number and you
don't want to have to potentially pay
him more if he would get cut the fact
that no one traded for him tells you
that there isn't going to be more out
there and i think this is going to
continue it's going to continue into
training camp in the preseason as teams
get more comfortable with other
arrangements
these veterans with bigger price tags
just because
they were on a team march april may june
july august may be when they end up
hitting the road
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports